dragon age inquisition multiplayer is
totally worth playing but it could be
better there are a number of things that
make the standalone multiplayer
experience worth playing so let's talk
about the good up front because I try to
be optimistic in this life first off
inquisitions multiplayer is delightfully
been jable each round last about 15 to
30 minutes less than half the typical
round of dota and it gave me a
distinctive case of one more round itís
this is just long enough to give a
satisfying experience but short enough
to keep things moving the added benefit
of having other humans controlling your
companions is also one of the modes
highs though Bioware his sense revealed
that Inquisition was initially a
multiplayer only project I might have
gathered that information anyway just
from playing the multiplayer mode with
other people not only do I feel less
lonely but your party responds more
intelligently to situations they pull
out and use potions when they're in
danger or they signal you when there's a
secret passage you've missed I wish I
could say the same for you Varrick bad
for morale would be an understatement
beyond the core mechanics inquisitions
multiplayer also has a surprising amount
of staying power despite the scant 3
maps included at launch it's just as
satisfying as it is in single-player to
build up your characters with new gear
improvements lot salad Diablo gems and
more importantly new skills in fact
acquiring new skills for your various
characters is arguably the most fun
aspect of this mode as the quick loop of
dungeon crawl level up and repeat allows
you a nearly instant payoff in the form
of testing out your new abilities or
weapons or what have you you can also
have as many characters as there are
classes and it takes some serious time
to unlock every single class if you're
not paying real money for chests you
need to craft the unlockable classes
armor in order to play as the assassin
rever and all the rest and it takes a
while to recruit the crafting materials
required you can only get materials from
salvaging other items and each item
doesn't provide very much material at
all and you need all of one type of
material in order to fill under the
slots and each armor has four different
material slots and on and on and on and
on you get the picture you also stand a
chance of randomly getting one of these
armor sets and the chest that you can
buy but I had no luck in that department
Oh more new characters and arenas have
been promised by Bioware as well which
will give this mode more staying power
as they roll out and now on to how it
could be better Bioware if you're
listening I love you guys but please
heed this advice because I really really
want to keep losing myself in this
multiplayer but it just isn't all there
yet the max level of 20 for each
character may take a while to reach but
it's definitely too limiting for those
who really want to pour themselves into
a single character that they
particularly like unlocking new skills
and bettering your characters the best
hook this mode has and if it's to retain
any longevity is going to need to be a
much higher level cap and hopefully more
skills to unlock you can however promote
a level 20 character back to level one
and it will grant every one of your
characters an additional attribute point
but I'd much rather continue to build
upon a character instead of prestiging
them back to level one it's ultimately
more satisfying to pour yourself into a
character over time than it is to just
sort of have them loop from level 20
back to one and slowly build up your
other characters with one point of
Constitution each time or something and
now for the real nitty gritty Bioware
please give us wow style arena duels can
you imagine the combat of Dragon Age
enough for v4 PvP arena imagine that
tactical class-based coordination coming
to blows as two teams with different
compositions take each other on there
could be such depth in the strategizing
and planning stage further this mode
could get dragon into a competitive
following seeing as the popularity of
spectating games like dota and starcraft
has skyrocketed in fact taking this idea
even further imagine a dota esque MOBA
style mode in dragon age where two teams
of four inquisitors attempt to capture
points and push their enemies back in a
smite esque matchup games like the a
prevention competitive Giants are still
popular years and years after their
releases because of the dynamic human
element that they include in their
gameplay when you're playing dragon ages
instances over and over and over you see
the same enemies in the same
environments and situations repeatedly
oh hey Rock guy how you doing it's been
a while been like 20 minutes or
something right when you're playing a
round of dota there may only be one map
but every round is a completely
different experience because your
primary enemies are thinking feeling
human being sitting at their own
computers and trying to win for their
own reasons another interesting idea
could be a sort of asymmetrical dungeon
master mode in which one player directs
the actions and makeup of the enemy
hordes different scenarios would arise
every playthrough and even
if you were limited to the three maps
available currently each time you load
it in you would have no idea what to
expect from your foes the types of
enemies that you find and their
strategies can be completely different
from every other time you've ever played
moreover this could evolve into much
more than just a map editor type deal
and allow players to have a digital
Dungeons and Dragons sort of experience
in which the dungeon master can present
them with in-depth decisions or
narrative scenarios that unfold as you
make their way through overall
inquisitions multiplayer is a truly
great start as a standalone multiplayer
experience it's extremely fun rewarding
and well-paced but with little staying
power once you level your favorite
character to completion however as a
platform upon which Bioware will
inevitably expand this game could be
huge